[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Nature Valley
always has had, for the past
three years, a great
relationship with
the National Parks.
It seemed like a natural fit
for us if they're doing a
Preserve the Parks Program,
why would we not actually
digitally start to preserve
these parks?
So the notion of marrying Street
View with, what we're
calling Trail View, seemed
like a very natural
progression.
MALE SPEAKER 2: We looked at
some other mapping engines,
and most of them work
like a crab.
So you traverse the world like
a crab in 2D view, and that's
not acceptable anymore.
Right around October of last
year, Street View became
actually enabled with web GL and
it gave us a 3D view, and
that was actually exposing
the API.
So I didn't look back.
I just went ahead and selected
that as a platform of choice.
I think the problem we
faced was just the
massive share of footage--
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER 2: --is really
unconventional.
And I would say, if you can
shoot that much and bring it
back to the lab, that's great.
But take your diligence in
picking the right format and
be patient in producing the
highest quality anything, and
the idea will be there to carry
you all the way through.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Overall we've
been working on this platform
in what will be two years in
February, and we're continuing
to work on evolving
the platform.
MALE SPEAKER 1: It's one thing
to have an idea, but it's
completely another thing
just to watch it
sort of come to life.
We had no idea if this was
possible, how to do it.
And just surround yourself
with the best people and
that's what we did.
[MUSIC PLAYING]